d'interrogatoire c'est un autre type de
guerre qui se joue une guerre de
communication à tour de rôle des soldats
d'ukrainiens faits prisonniers son fils
mais ils sont présentés comme ayant fait
désertion comme ils sont détenus nous ne
montrons pas leur visage les forces
séparatistes leur demande de témoigner
devant une caméra
dans quel régal j tu étais à fonctions
53e brigade mécanisée unité cinq équipes
le but démoralisé l'autre camp ces
vidéos sont diffusées pour pousser les
soldats d'ukrainiens qui combattent
encore à rendre les armes
on a rendu les armes calmement personne
ne nous tabasser
un à un ils doivent signer un acte de
reddition les soldats leur promettent de
pouvoir contacter leur famille puis nous
autorise à leur poser des questions
tout l'entretien est filmé nous sommes
surveillés
roslan à 27 ans il est originaire de la
partie du donbass contrôlée par kiev il
nous dit avoir rejoint l'armée
ukrainienne en octobre il est détenu
depuis deux jours
nous savons très bien traités les
militaires nous ont donné la même chose
à manger comme
impossible de savoir si le dit la vérité
mais sa peur elle semble bien réelle
oui
oui nous avons peur car nous ne savons
pas ce que nous allons devenir ram
rentrer à la maison j'ai tellement envie
de rentrer et que la guerre se termine
de leur côté aussi les ukrainien diffuse
des vidéos de soldats ennemis qu'ils
auraient capturé ils ont même monté un
site dédié où il met aussi des photos de
soldats russes qui auraient été tués au
combat